[Music]  we are gonna play the Kylie quiz and see  how well do you know me Kylie Jenner  puts Travis Scott to the test in a game  of 23 questions but one fact the rapper  was quick to answer what is Kylie's  biggest scar on her body which she shows  off on the couple's joint GQ cover the  biggest scar on your leg over the years  the lipcott creator has been open about  loving the scar that runs down her leg  and explained the blemish was caused by  a childhood injury while playing with  sister Kendall Jenner Kylie said quote  when I was about five my sister and I  were playing hide and seek and I hid  inside this really tall and closed gate  adding after a while when my sister  didn't find me I had to climb up on this  sharp pulse sticking out from the gate I  slipped in the pole went into my leg